our planet is so beautiful when the sun
is low
the outsiders ravage our lands
[Music]
you'll need to face your fears
do not trespass in our lands
the desert was ours long before you came
back to leah
my lord
it's all right
the desert isn't kind
you wouldn't want to go down out there
it's we're in territory
who are you to the fremen
no dreams
the future i can see it
i need you by my side well if i'm not in
the future of house of treaty
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be my son
will you protect our son
with
my life
why didn't you say you were a fighter
jessica you've been training him in the
way do you see so little hope
a path has been laid let's hope he
doesn't squander it
let's fight like demons
put on some muscle
i didn't no
[Music]
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
and he answers
my son
we'll find a way
hello young master
why is dr youth here spice is a
psychoactive chemical you seem to be
sensitive
i've been having dreams they're picking
my family off one by one
[Applause]
smile gurney i am smiling
you've never met harkins before they're
not human they're brutal
i'm on the moon today
you fight when the necessity arises
fight
i see you found the mood
you